- First of all, thank you guys so much.
I wanna thank the
amazingly handsome Barney.
(crowd cheering)
(laughing)
What do you think about that, looks good?
Looks good, okay.
All right, lets do some Q and A.
(hip hop music)
♪ You getting stuck ♪
♪ Got your feed in the mud ♪
♪ You have been caught in a flood ♪
♪ While the water is unparted ♪
♪ We run reap what you sow ♪
♪ The harvest is us ♪
♪ You have been enjoying life ♪
♪ Sipping the syrup ♪
♪ And aligning the white ♪
♪ Taking whatever you touch ♪
♪ The shorter the wick ♪
♪ It is covered in blood ♪
Who's got a question?
Go ahead.
- Me?
- Yep.
- If we're trying to solve--
- What's your name?
- Kenta.
- You retweet my tweet about
don't read Gary V. before you sleep
- That's what's up.
- Because you're gonna (mumbling)
- Yes, that's true.
(laughing)
- So my question is, I'm doing an app,
an entire platform about solving
procrastination in people.
What do you think is the number one
reason that people procrastinate?
- Their mindset's broken.
At the most high--
- Can you solve that with an app?
- I don't know.
Let me rephrase.
Probably.
I mean, look, how many people have been
positively effected by my content?
(crowd cheering)
So you know, like, right,
like there's something,
I don't know exactly what it is.
To my my big thing is,
I don't want, you know,
I'm trilled that I've
motivated you to do something,
but I think I've motivated
people to do something
out of practicality and truth.
I'm not here to coddle you.
I'm here to tell you the truth.
And actually, how many people here,
when they first came across
me, actually didn't like me?
Raise your hand?
(audience mumbling)
And the reason that is is because
I'm going so hard at the truth
that if you're not in the right place,
you're mad at me because
I'm calling you out
on your shit and that's uncomfortable.
I feel that, you know like,
it's just the way it is.
So probably, but it's very
deeply grounded in psychology.
And you have to have those skillsets
in that app to get there.
- Thanks.
- Go ahead, my man.
Yes.
- I'm trying to grow a brand around
Caribbean and African food.
- Yes.
That's good.
I'm hungry, too.
(laughing)
- You have like a specific episode
where you telling one guy that actually
created a show and
(mumbling) interview people.
You're great at creating pillars,
creating content from conduct.
I'm just curious, for
food related, like my--
- Let's start with this,
and I'm glad you actually
asked this question.
I think the biggest thing that I just
took away from all this,
besides all the
ridiculously warm feelings,
is my concern/curiosity,
if you really know
what your finish line is.
Or at least a finish line.
Not maybe your ultimate finish line.
But A.
Let's start with you, let's
use this for everybody.
Okay, you wanna start a brand around
that food culture, right?
- Yeah.
- If I told you I'm a weird
fucking genie from the future
and I could make the
first great thing happen,
what's the first great thing?
- So what I want to
happen is I want to create
the biggest media company centered around,
I call it Black Food Club.
That's what I want to create.
- And so you wanna make that successful
and live off of it and
that's your life, right?
You make, whether you make
$500,000 a year, $39,000 a year,
40, obviously you gotta
pay for your lifestyle.
But what do you think the
minimum amount of money
you wanna make for your life?
Like what would be the
minimum amount of money
that you make every year
that allowed you to live
and do that content media site?
What do you think?
- Maybe 40, 50,000 pounds, maybe.
- Great, so you're, what
is amazing about that is,
if that's where you're at,
well then at this young of an age,
and that's where you're at,
and the fact that you're
even here and you know,
it's just unbelievable amounts of content
in written, audio, and visual form
on Instagram, Snapchat, Facebook,
Twitter, and YouTube, and podcasts,
and I will tell you, I would flabbergasted
in three, four, five, six
years, unless you suck,
which you may.
(laughing)
But if you don't suck,
and you have that little
of a financial need, which is remarkable.
Which is the biggest thing.
Somebody here, I don't
know if they're here
said you made me realize
I didn't need Rolexes
and things of that nature, right?
The biggest reason so
many of you will fail
is your number for success
is far greater than his.
You think you need a million,
which will then mean that
you're gonna do a lot of things
when you don't get a million very quickly,
that won't ever get you a million.
So if you think what I just said is cool,
which is bleed for six years in a row,
you'll probably get
sponsorship or sales of product
at $40,000 a year.
To me, that's what I did.
I knew what I wanted.
I was willing to give up my 20s for it.
Gave 'em up.
Somebody said it's difficult
not to document right now.
I'm like, but I didn't.
Should I build my business
or should I document?
I'm like, both.
He's like well I gotta pick one,
I'm like, build your business.
So if your ambitions are that humble,
which they are, that's
incredible, that excites me.
Because by the way, here's the funny part,
that's who I was too.
I just needed $100,000 a year.
- That's all I need.
That seemed rich to me.
I was like cool, I'll be
okay, I'll have a house,
it's not, you know, I
just needed the game.
And too many people,
too many of you in here
want the stuff, not the game.
When you fall in love with the game,
everything's different,
because you've already won.
That's real, it sounds cliche.
But it's real.
- Yeah, I haven't really
figured out myself yet,
but since I work for (mumbling) company,
I just wanna bring more money
and get 10% commission
from sales (mumbles)
in your London office.
- You know, Davy's right there,
he's right, you can start pitching him.
- Davy (mumbling)
(laughing)
(mumbling)
- So I'm obsessed with London.
I mean, we have an office here, right?
There's a lot of places
I can have an office.
Especially with a creative shop.
Like Amsterdam, there's a
lotta places I coulda chose.
I'm a huge fan of London.
I'm a huge fan of this country.
I'm just a big fan, man.
You know, the food's okay.
(laughing)
Because I grew up in the wine business,
so I know there's a
bunch of Italian dudes,
like Italy, France, right?
I was spoiled in my 20s
Europe meant wine country
which meant great food
countries, France, Italy,
France, Italy, Spain,
France, Italy, Germany,
like it was funny.
I've never been to London
until I was like 32 years old.
And I was like oh shit, the food sucks.
You know, like,
(laughing)
but as an American,
who was born in eastern Europe,
there's a lot of romance
I have towards London,
'cause it's just further ahead.
But it also shows me
all the vulnerabilities
that America has over
the next 100, 200 years.
I think the biggest problem in general
with western Europe is the
alpha side of me doesn't respect
the way the game is played.
So I don't like have an office in London
because if that good looking
man right next to you sucks,
I can't really fire him,
and I think that's stupid.
Like the laws of doing business
in Europe are such bullshit.
And they're soft.
And that's why China and Asia and America
will always beat Europe in the game.
- Real quick,
Similar to (mumbling) earlier,
like on the streets of different cities,
all around the tube,
things are going well,
just under 20,000 followers on Facebook,
(mumbling) everything.
Is it too early to look for sponsorship?
- When I cold called a beer company.
(mumbling)
Yeah, I mean, there's like,
I called some company,
like I was trying to teach
people you can sell at any point,
I went to Google, 'cause there
was no social really yet,
and there as a company
that was advertising beer
and I called them,
put on speaker and told them,
I'm starting a beer blog,
I have a wine blog, I wasn't going to,
but I was trying to teach everybody,
and the guy was down for the conversation.
What I think you need to be careful of,
is I think where people get caught,
is they overpromise and under-deliver.
It's too early if you're
gonna tell some company
that if they give you a thousand,
it's gonna be good for their business.
It's gonna be good for you.
(mumbling)
- What kinda brand do you
think is kinda relevant?
- You know the answer.
You fucking know the answer.
You're just trying to
make some more content,
which I respect.
(laughing)
Go ahead.
Yeah.
- So first of all, you're the fucking man.
All your shit's insane.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- Today I lost 50% of
all the money that I had,
people are ditching me
because they don't want to
go to the conference anymore,
so I've been just full on fucking pissed.
- [Gary] Right, getting shit on today.
- All day, yeah.
- [Gary] That sounds awesome.
Yeah, I like it.
- Yeah, fucking hit me.
- I like it, I'll tell you why,
because even I can tell by your demeanor
that you're gonna be okay.
The fact that you realize
that that negative moment
has positive impact, the
question is why'd it happen.
And that's where you have
to be honest with yourself.
I don't know, you know, but that's,
you know, I'm pumped
that you can have the,
I mean, you're more positive
than half the people here,
and it sounds like you're
having a terrible day.
(laughing)
- Feeling like shit, you
know, like super rage.
That's why I wanted to ask you,
how do you keep the
positivity and the calmness
when everything is just hitting the fan?
- Because basically when things
happen, I go the other way.
So tonight I just was
reminding myself every time,
every time you came and
the next person came,
I was just reminding me,
literally in my own head,
saying you don't mean shit.
I said it to one of you.
They said, "How do you stay humble
"when you're so successful?"
I'm like because I know if I die tomorrow
I'll have a good day on social media.
(laughing)
Most comments ever on my
latest post on Instagram,
everybody's gonna be like,
"Oh fuck, that was the last one, weird."
And I know that all of you will be on
with your life a week later.
You have to balance your ego with humility
in the same way, when
I'm having my worst day,
I realize I'm the best,
I'm gonna be the best that ever does this.
And so the way I handle things is when
something's going one way, I
use all my emotional strength
to push the other way.
What are you gonna cry
for the rest of your life
because your conference got fucked up?
(laughing)
Like I just, to me it's just like,
what the fuck's going,
guys, if you're in this room right now,
let me just remind you that
there are 7.7 billion people.
Literally right now as we stand here,
there are women being shipped to be
strippers in parts of our world.
Right now as we stand
here, there are women
who are basically caged mentally, usually,
and are being shipped to
dance on a poll in Manhattan,
and in London, like do you understand,
there's genocide going on right now.
Like, what do you think's going on?
We lack perspective.
Your conference got fucked up?
Boo hoo.
I lost a client?
There's people fucking dying out there.
So when Americans or
Europeans talk to me about
race or gender, I'm sad,
it's their real life,
but I remind them, because
it's a positive thing,
cool, but lemme tell you about the person
that's ranked 7 billion in the world.
They fucking have it bad.
And so I just, I struggle.
I wanna, listen I'm weird,
I think about things like animals.
Like, I don't know.
If you're the best elephant,
we are still better than you.
(laughing)
We got, listen, you know I got hot on this
about a year ago, the 400 trillion to one,
it's impossible to be a human being.
You won.
I don't know how to get upset after that.
I keep shit in perspective.
Right?
Like you're gonna learn from this.
You fucked up.
I promise you, it's
failing because of you.
And when you start owning your shit,
and not blaming other people,
and I think this is the kick
I've been on lately on
Instagram, blame yourself.
You know why I'm always happy?
I blame myself.
When you blame yourself for real,
you're gonna always be happy.
Because you don't feel like
somebody else controls you.
- [Audience Member] It's
crazy that no one gets that
when you tell them as well.
- You know.
And listen, think about all the
shit I've said on Instagram,
you see it, you've been into
my shit for three months,
you see it, and you're like,
"What the fuck does he mean?"
Right?
Like it's about eliminating
being at the mercy of anything or anyone.
Right?
It's mental minimalism.
Just being like real basic,
I'm basic as fuck up here.
It's binary.
(laughing)
I mean it, I mean it.
I'm really basic.
Good, bad.
Black, white.
On me, on me, on me.
My fault.
There's nothing you can say.
The venue fucked you?
You picked the venue.
- I got scammed.
Somebody scammed--
- Your fault.
Your fault.
- I know, and I totally get it, but.
- Your fault, because
you fucking cut a corner.
The only time you get scammed
is when you cut corners.
- Under-price attention.
(mumbling)
My religion.
- How did you find,
so let's just say if it's on Facebook now,
how do you know, how do you say,
do you go okay it might be
on Twitter like in two years,
or how do you go about finding
that under-priced attention
and how do you know it's under-priced?
- Too many of you have
ego around your time
when it's the only thing you got.
So the reason I always
know is 'cause I work.
'Cause I work.
I work.
I try things, I test,
I DM you back, I tweet.
I work so when you're
in shit, you taste it.
And when you've done it for
20 years, you see patterns.
Facebook's still under-priced,
you just can't target 22 to 25 year old
African American fans of Facebook
because other people
are doing that too now.
It's just like Google.
Early on you could just target soccer.
One word, five cents a click.
I did it.
Wine.
(clicking)
But then I had to put, at
the end of the game, now,
I gotta put 2013 Heller Cellar
Zinfandel, like long tail.
Real Estate.
If you're right about London,
like this is my favorite,
do understand that somebody once
bought this building for a dollar?
Somebody bought the land
we're on for a dollar once.
That happened.
It was a long time ago.
How do you know?
You're a practitioner.
The reason I do is to how I learn.
You gotta put up, all of you are like,
"Well I can't do podcasting,
and Facebook, and Twitter.
"Oh by I can vlog, but I can't..."
Why?
If you want it so bad?
My thing is why.
If you want it so bad, why can't,
if you wanna have a media company
around Caribbean food
culture, why can't you?
You know what I wanna see?
I wanna see all your minutes.
(laughing)
I wanna give you DRock for the day,
I wanna watch you from
the moment you wake up,
to the moment you go to sleep.
Lemme promise you something,
you're gonna get exposed.
(mumbling)
So that's why Daily V happened.
Because you guys, like a lot of you
didn't know before Daily V.
How many people knew me before Daily V?
Not bad.
Right.
You got to really know me post Daily V.
- Yeah.
- You heard hard work and hustle before,
you were confused.
And I've been doing that
shit every day for 20 years.
- I've been hustling for two
years to get an internship.
- You and 10,000 other people.
(audience mumbling)
DRock, how'd you get your job?
(laughing)
(mumbling)
But he offered me something that,
you have to understand,
you know how many people
offered me free videos today?
Everybody.
Big problem, I don't need it.
- Timing.
- That's right, for all of us.
- (mumbling) it's amazing.
- Go ahead, tell 'em.
Tell 'em, real quick.
- I've seen your story live.
He just stand up on a conference,
and I said I want to see
your DRock in London.
(mumbling)
- And timing, right?
Like, listen, I want it for you,
like I didn't even know
that internship was,
you saw, I didn't know that it was off.
Like I'm trying, but I can't,
you know, do you know how many of
are about to email me?
Tomorrow I'm flying from
London to Austin, Texas,
which is a long flight,
and I'm gonna have a really good chance
of actually getting to it.
But if I don't, even though I told you
take a photo and email me tonight,
you got a real unlikely
chance of getting through.
The question is what do you do next?
Do you try again?
Some of you email me 11 times.
Still no answers.
The person next to you's gonna
email me tomorrow for the first
time and get a full answer.
It's just the game.
It's just the fucking game.
- But who wants it bad enough?
- But who wants it smart too?
I know you want it bad, I know
a lot of people want it bad,
it's about being thoughtful of how.
You know.
And I don't--
- Sorry, I got in touch
with your China team
when you said you wanted to go to China.
- I always talk about, to your point,
I'm glad you said that, that was cool.
(laughing)
Life is funny, Tyler, right,
learning so much, we're
getting really close,
literally was at the crossroads
of being a terrible community
manager at VaynerMedia.
This is not a joke.
Was it the first day or what day?
- [Tyler] The first.
- The first day that Tyler was AJ,
AJ was deciding between
Tyler and Nick Dio,
who I love and you may have seen too,
to be his next assistant.
If Tyler didn't get the
job, he woulda left.
- Yep.
- 'Cause he was like
fuck this, this is not,
I'm not getting it the way I want.
Life is funny.
AJ, on a flip of a coin,
I think, in his mind,
goes with Tyler.
The first day that
Tyler is AJ's assistant,
and in his inbox, we get
an email from a client?
- Yeah, the New York Jets.
- The New York Jets are our
client, which is amazing.
The New York Jets send AJ an email,
now Tyler sees all the emails,
and it says, AJ we'd love to talk to you,
we desperately want Tyler
Schmidt of the business.
(laughing)
But I wanna keep telling the story.
You have to understand,
if he wasn't in consideration
and AJ wasn't ready for an admin,
if he didn't get the admin job,
what would've happened was at that moment
we would have audited
what Tyler was up to.
Tyler was not in the right head space
because he knew that wasn't right for him.
When we audited, more thank likely,
it woulda came back and and been like
yeah, he's really not that good.
And he probably would've got fired.
Life is funny.
So the reason I'm telling
some of these stories is,
guys, there's a time when
I've done a trip to LA,
it got canceled, maybe that was the trip
that I was gonna have the
meeting that was change my life.
I sat in San Francisco twice and
passed on Uber in the angel round,
right to my good friend's face.
Had I said yes, I would have three to four
hundred million dollars more right now.
That's real life.
I don't know what else to tell you.
That happened in my life.
So there's just so many variables.
And this is why if you
listen, I keep shit simple,
because you think you're way
more in control than you are.
You're in control when
you make the decision,
you're not in control after that.
Why do I make decisions so easily?
Because I know I'm never
gonna know the alternative.
Why did we pick London?
Anyone can do London
We talked about other things,
like everything is so much
chance than you think.
Which is why if you keep
it basic, shit works out.
All of you are just spending so much time
overthinking shit you have
no fucking control over.
- Gary?
- Yeah.
- I just started my personal brand.
I've been introduced (mumbles).
I've heard so much from you.
All the podcasts, all the videos.
But still, I'm providing full
service travel organization,
and besides Facebook
ads and Instagram ads,
what could I do more?
Because I'm literally thinking about--
- Are they working?
- Sorry?
- Is it working?
Have you done 'em yet?
- My first group is next week.
- Have you done the ads?
- Sorry?
Your first group of ads.
- I haven't.
I will do it, I just
need basic information.
I will do it.
- But here me out.
The fact that you're
asking for what else works
when you haven't felt the benefits
of the thing that's come
out of my fucking mouth
every day for 18 months.
(laughing)
But think.
You understand?
No but really, it's like,
I'm like, there's a great deal over here,
and you're saying, but is
there even a better deal
somewhere yet that you haven't.
(laughing)
That's not right.
- Okay, not right.
- Listen, and you know,
I'm never gonna waiver,
it's all about patience.
You've literally, let's just,
I wanna drill this
through your fucking head.
You literally are curious
about the other thing.
You haven't even tasted
the fruits of the thing,
it's a bad indicator of
what's about to happen.
- I'm trying to run faster.
I know it's long game.
- Yeah, but all of you say shit to me,
and then I watch you and you don't do it.
All of you are cool with me
when we're here together
for three seconds.
"Oh my God, thank you.
"Yeah, patience, I got you."
(laughing)
And then I got look at,
but you know, just so
you guys know what I do,
this is how I learn,
because I do the work.
I go and I'll tonight at
one o'clock in the morning
or on a flight, will look
at all the photos, hashtags,
be like, cool, yeah I remember that kid,
oh yeah, that's the
Caribbean dude, you know.
And then I'll save shit.
And then I'll, you think
it's cool when I follow you.
(laughing)
And then I go back and I look.
- Thank you.
I'm more hungry than ever.
Thank you.
- Good.
Do you understand?
And like you seemed
hungry two minutes ago.
So you see where I'm going?
You see where I'm going?
Guys, what I sell for
free by the way, is hard.
Man, it's fucking hard.
Like if it was so easy,
(mumbling)
it's fucking hard.
- Hey, sorry.
First of all I really wanted to thank you,
'cause there's people who, like you say,
I lost everything, I
almost work on the street,
I'm a busker, I play guitar here with me.
And I went from having
a girlfriend, my home,
leaving my country, a car, a bike,
to having nothing and living
literally on the street.
And all I had was your
videos and your content
and it really made me push
forward from having nothing.
So thank you for that.
And the thing is for writing lyrics,
I'm trying to go full
Ed Sheeran on this shit.
Like write, I have a
problem with perfectionism,
because I want it so bad.
To do some good content.
- And you're also an artist.
- Yes.
- So when you're an
artist, you're in trouble.
- Yes.
- You're vulnerable.
- I write some lyrics, I write good music,
but the lyrics I'm having trouble
because so perfectionist.
I'm always correcting myself.
So I just can never put
all the content in...
- You have to put it out.
Bro, listen, there's tomorrow.
There's tomorrow.
I don't know what else to say,
this is why I think you should
document and not create,
everybody's overthinking shit.
Tomorrow, tomorrow, tomorrow, tomorrow.
Like, you just have to
understand that you're wrong.
It's not even about, it's not subjective,
put the fucking song out.
Like whatever fucking rhymes
with tree this time is good enough.
(laughing)
I'm telling you, dog.
- Last one.
(mumbling)
- Yes, yes.
You're welcome so much.
I got you, Moscow.
(mumbling)
Shh, shh.
What's that?
- I'm 27 years old and
basically I used to do anything creative,
that's what I did, used
to wall murals, anything.
Had a son, went into
midwifery for three years.
- Went into what?
- Midwifery for three years,
got my degree and I
said, I'm not doing that.
Because it's not what I want to do.
- It made you unhappy?
- Not unhappy, but it
wasn't want I wanted to do.
- Neutral.
- So now am just starting
to open my own business,
and I got my first client.
I'm doing her social media
and rebranding her business.
My question is, I thought
of an amazing idea
for her business, I'm
not 100% business minded,
so I'm gonna just give it
to her and work with it.
But then I spoke to my friend's mom
who was a lawyer and she was like,
"No, that's your idea,
you need to license it."
- That's a stupid idea.
- Okay.
- You don't need to license it.
- Okay, cool.
- That's dumb lawyer talk in 2018.
(laughing)
Now, you can sell your
time and your advice.
You could also give it away,
because if you give it away,
it may lead to the next thing.
It all comes to how you wanna play it.
But if somebody isn't business savvy,
it's because they're
scared to ask for money.
I'll be very honest with you.
I don't like asking for money.
I'm not, I don't like it.
By the way, it's probably
one of the reasons
you all like me so much,
I don't like asking.
(laughing)
I'm really good at bringing
value so that it comes,
passively, indirectly,
but you definitely aren't gonna license.
What your friend's mom,
and I'm sure she's lovely,
doesn't understand, is ideas as IP
in today's internet
world is not working out.
That's old school thinking, pre internet.
- Even for a name?
Yeah, I mean, like you
have a name for her brand?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I mean, you could ask her for $500
for a brand name and maybe you
pay somebody a hundred bucks,
or five bucks on Fiverr for a logo.
You see where I'm going?
Sometimes you need to add something to,
maybe you don't like how
it feels to have a name,
but you might like how it
feels to have a name and a logo
because you feel like
you're giving her something,
a logo.
- My issue is she may never
blow up, but she might.
And if she blows up and I'm
like hey, that was my idea.
- Yep, I get it.
Why do you think everybody
fucking gives us free music?
It's exposure.
Alright, Moscow Yoga, I
know it's the last one, but
I promise you, you're welcome, go ahead.
- I just wanna say thank you for the gift.
I wanna give to you,
nothing is more basic to me
than putting people in handstand.
I would love to put you on
your hands right now, man.
- Okay, let's go.
Let's go.
(crowd cheering)
I don't know, I've never done it.
(mumbling)
Here we fucking go.
I'm really upset I picked on him.
Like fuck.
I lost.
- [Man] You lost.
- I fucking lost.
Out of all the people
to pick, this fucking...
- Two, three.
(crowd cheering)
(clapping)
- Thank you so much.
I love you!
(crowd cheering)
(hip hop music)
♪ You have been caught in the flood ♪
♪ You have been ♪